all right people we are alive on the
YouTube via your internet computer
machine I haven't done one of these live
streams in a while and there's a lot of
stuff going on that is the
understatement of the century so I just
want to take a little time and then just
chat with you guys for an hour an hour
and a half or so just get some thoughts
out there a lot of chatter about all
sorts of different things so I just
wanted to to check in with you and just
kind of get you up to speed on some
stuff there's a lot of good stuff
happening right now there's also some
annoying stuff happening that's okay
so yeah I haven't known one of these in
a while and I just wanted to to catch up
so hello so first off before we do
anything else we crossed a million
subscribers two or three weeks ago on
YouTube which is it's a pretty big
milestone and I think we're getting some
sort of golden button or a silver widget
or something from YouTube they have told
us we are getting something to
commemorate that so that's nice I think
probably what I'm most proud of beyond
sort of the content of the show which
I'm going to talk about quite a bit
today is the fact that we have built
this thing with literally literally zero
ad dollars we've never put a dollar into
advertising on YouTube so the million
Plus now of you that our subscribers
you've come to us either through you
know searching or suggested videos or
watching me on something else or
whatever the YouTube ecosystem creates
or what however you podcast or whatever
you do you've somehow come here and a
million people that's a lot of people I
know it's not PewDiePie you know what am
I like 200 million people behind him but
you know we all can't be Beauty pie but
I think for somebody doing something
pretty decent in the political space a
million subscribers is pretty sweet and
the fact that we did it all organically
is pretty awesome
so I'm excited about that and I just
haven't had a chance to do one of these
live streams just to kind of thank you
guys for that so a heartfelt thank you
for getting us to cross the million
threshold it does seem to me
that when you hit a million that the
algorithm does start treating you a
little bit differently and you know
there's a there's a weird optics thing
so like it seems like if you're if you
have 800,000 subscribers that still
doesn't seem sort of mainstream there's
something that I can just sense and I
can just see about sort of articles that
are being written about me which I'll
talk about a little bit just sort of
like the types of journalists that are
reaching out to me or people either
complimenting me or going after me on
Twitter or whatever else that's
something about a million seems like
much more mainstream or something like
that not that I even want to be
mainstream I don't even know that
mainstream is a thing anymore like what
really is mainstream I mean if you think
about it like you know basically we're
running out of things that are sort of
just mainstream and that we all sort of
coalesce around right so it's like if
you just think about it from a news
perspective let's say you know 20 30
years ago or even more you had three
Network news right yeah at ABC you at
NBC you at CBS I mean basically all sort
of said the same thing one might have
leaned a little bit this way one might
have leaned a little bit this way you
might have liked Tom Brokaw more than
you like Peter Jennings or you might
have liked Walter Cronkite more than
this guy or whatever and that's the one
that you would watch and that's how sort
of how you get your news and we sort of
had this mainstream set of ideas that
you know the Overton Window sort of
encompassed the whole thing and you know
you could shift a little bit but that we
all sort of accepted the same the same
basic ideas and that's sort of all the
information we got then cable news came
in one leans left one leans right one
leans nowhere that you know which one
I'm talking about they pretend to lean
nowhere you know whatever CNN point is
that then YouTube came around and there
are quite literally millions and
millions of people that you can get your
information from that you can listen to
conversations listen to podcast talk
about ideas all sorts of things and it's
not just politics of course if you care
about video games if you care about
unboxing videos if you care about
fashion if you care about makeup all of
these things all of these different
competing voices and this platform which
often I express my frustration with and
I'm still frustrated with them there's
all sorts of things going on with the
algorithm where we sense they're you
know suppressing some of our videos or
messing with us a little bit and we're
working on that we just hired somebody
to do it
audit of our YouTube channel to make
sure we're optimizing properly and all
of those things but there's a beauty of
the platform and any of these platforms
in that it allows regular people to get
their ideas out there so it's like if
you like what I do that you could
subscribe watch if you don't then you
don't have to subscribe and watch and
that is sort of what's so interesting
right now about this move 2d platform
people because nobody's forcing anyone
to watch anything as far as I know I
mean there might be some torture device
in somebody's basement somewhere where
they're forcing people to watch videos
of somebody but basically if you don't
like something you change the channel or
you click away and that's it
so this need or this sort of newfound
desire by a certain set of people to
deep platform people because they don't
like their ideas or even more
dangerously they don't like people that
they talk to or a whole different set of
things is I think I think an extremely
dangerous place to be in and we're
watching more and more accounts get shut
down and all that stuff and and look we
can openly discuss you know which ideas
should be on which platforms and as
private companies these companies you
know my belief on this these companies
can do whatever they want to do and then
there is some issue related to how much
connection do the big tech companies
Google and Facebook and Twitter etc have
with the government and all sorts of
things and also are these new ways of
communication YouTube Twitter etc are
they are they public in that they are
the way we communicate so should they be
regulated the way we would regulate the
water company or the telephone company
or something like that these are all
rich discussions that I've had on the
show and will continue to discuss but I
say all that really just to say wow a
million a you subscribe to this thing I
can't believe how huge this thing's got
and and you know just in the last year
or so
traveling with Jordan Peterson and a
hundred plus cities in around 20
countries and going to meeting people
all over the world and it will come as
no surprise to you guys that people in
real life and they're really out there
real human beings that you can touch and
you know or three-dimensional and all
that they're actually much nicer than
the anonymous Twitter trolls
so that's the funny thing is like I get
so much love constantly and support and
all this stuff and we're fan funded and
it's all great and then people will say
oh but you get a lot of hate sometimes
people come up to you on street they're
like how do you deal with all the hate
I'm like well the hate really isn't real
you know it's a lot of manufactured
nonsense but I can't say one thing about
that which is that ironically the more
hate that I get the more that I think
I'm doing something good it's like when
you're doing something good or something
that you think is good and you're doing
what you enjoy doing whatever it is it's
like that just sort of feels right you
don't have to really think about it a
lot then when you're doing something
like that and you start getting a lot of
hate for it
and usually I'm not talking about legit
criticism which I often reference and
I'll gladly reference some of it here
I'm talking about just like endless hate
go [ __ ] yourself and all sorts of just
conspiratorial nonsense and you know all
the just the general sort of collection
of losers who just want to get clicks
off you and all of those things it's
like boy I must really be doing
something good all I really wanted to do
was have decent honest conversation and
then that somehow become controversial
and that was the point from the
beginning it's like I saw years ago that
like everybody was starting to hate each
other at all different levels nobody
wanted to talk I started doing something
where people could come together and
talk and now that has become that in and
of itself has become controversial in a
way so in a weird way it's just like oh
well this is just more affirmation that
I guess I'm doing something pretty
decent here so anyway as far as the the
subscription thing do me a favor people
because I meet you guys
supermarket or free at the Brigham
bowling alley last week and people call
me and say that they are subscribed but
then they get unsubscribed and all that
so right now if you are not subscribed
just just click the subscribe thing over
there if you wouldn't mind if you if you
like what we're doing here and if you
are subscribed or even if you're
clicking it right now click that that
bell there that's the notifications
where you can make sure that you're
actually getting notifications when our
new videos come out because people are
not getting videos in the in the feed
and a bunch of other stuff our Rev on on
YouTube this month is now going to be
down by like 70 percent or something
it's all it's all messy and where we're
working are all sorts of other things
but anyway that's the that's the YouTube
portion of
of this so more than anything else I
really I'm just appreciative of a
million of you guys that that dig this
thing and you know I think we're going
to we're gonna keep keep growing and
keep doing good stuff and and somehow
try to clean up a little bit of the mess
I think that's what I've been trying to
do here
not always succeeding at it but doing my
best to try to clean up a little bit of
the conversation a little bit of the
mess try to find allies and people that
I maybe thought were my ideological
enemies a couple years ago open up
avenues for for people that have maybe
done some wrong things in the past to
kind of make a comeback you know so I
had Mike's turn of echad I think this is
really interesting I had Mike Stern
Abidjan what was that about two or three
weeks ago now now I hadn't had him on
for about three years I had him on
originally three years ago and I said
this to him as he was sitting right here
that the reason I had him on the first
time is that it was right at the
beginning of the Trump thing and nobody
in mainstream media was really talking
about Trump as any sort of serious thing
but I kept seeing it bubble up on
Twitter and I was like well I want to
get somebody on the show that will talk
about Trump but I couldn't really find
anyone that seemed legit like I could
see all these me makers but I couldn't
find anyone that was like an author or a
public person or anything that would
openly support Trump and then I came
across this guy Mike Serna [ __ ] now
again this is three plus years ago and
this was when the show was on or a TV
and I find this guy Mike Stern to Mitch
and I see he's a published author author
and I bring him in and he basically we
talked for about an hour and he
explained what he thinks is happening
with the mainstream media and what
what's happening with trumpism and all
of those things and that was one of
several conversations I would also
include Scott Adams in this know though
that was about a year later that led me
to believe that the Trump thing was
actually real and he had a legitimate
chance of becoming president which is
why when I was on Joe Rogan I think the
second time was the day before the day
before in the day of the election and I
was like yeah Trump might win because I
had been listening to these people it
didn't I didn't support Trump and I
didn't vote for Trump but I didn't have
Trump derangement syndrome either but it
was more that I had just been having
conversations with people that were
explaining what was going on here so all
of the media people and the elites that
were all shocked that day it was like
well if you guys would have just been
paying attention
or it or talk to some people that you
would consider unsavory maybe you
wouldn't be so shocked right now so in
any event I had certain Abidjan about
three years ago then I let it go for
about three years and over the course of
the last three years he's done stuff
that we just talked about two or three
weeks ago he was involved in the pizza
gate thing he got he was one of the
people that led James Gunn who's the
guardians of the galaxy director to get
fired over some old tweets and we talked
about all of those things I had him on a
couple weeks ago and the reason I had
him on it was because I've seen the guy
moderate himself over the past year and
I think everyone deserves a second
chance not only not only a second chance
I think most of us probably deserve a
third chance a fourth chance maybe even
a fifth chance like none of us are
perfect we're all coming up through this
technological adolescence together like
right we've all been just handed all of
this stuff and the way that trolling is
and destroying people and selectively
adding video and now you can see these
new videos these deep fake videos where
they can make it seem like someone is
saying something that they're not saying
and they can edit it together so it
looks like your mouth is moving with
different words I mean we have a whole
new technological frontier that we have
no idea how to really deal with coming
so anyway we all make mistakes along the
way and I've seen Serna Mitch
as someone that moderated over the last
year and I thought it would be worth
having that conversation again and I'll
continue by the way to have those
conversations I know I get a ton of [ __ ]
for it and I know there's a certain set
of people that don't want me to talk to
another certain set of people but I will
do what I think is right I really will
now along along that road there's going
to be some mistakes and there's gonna be
some errors and things of that nature
but I will consistently do what I think
is right and you know the idea that
we're gonna just boot people off these
platforms now we're gonna get rid of all
of these voices and that that's somehow
gonna make us better or more tolerant or
something like that I just simply don't
believe in it now look on the private
side they can do what they want and I
mentioned earlier if they have enough
connections now to government it's like
I don't know if these are public or
private companies anymore maybe a good
use of public money I mean this is a
place where I think that there could be
some good use of state governmental
money which is really just the
people's money would be that maybe we
need fully funded platforms that allow
everybody to be on there as long as you
don't break the laws of the United
States so they were not so reliant on
these private companies I'm not really
sure that that's the answer either and
as you guys know Jordan Peterson and I
have been working on some stuff let me
hold that portion of the conversation
back just a little bit but I'll just
keep having these conversations with
people and see what happens so with that
in mind there's been some interesting
stuff happening just sort of to me
personally and within within this space
let's say over the past couple weeks so
those of you that are active on Twitter
god bless ya you probably saw that a
couple weeks ago I invited mayor Pete
Pete Budaj on the show via Twitter now
sometimes I invite people on the show
via Twitter
sometimes we go through the proper
channels via websites or public
relations people or their series of ways
you can get you know sometimes it's a
personal connection holds a whole series
away that you can get different guests
on the show in this case we didn't have
a contact for mayor Pete so I saw that
his comms person I think it was was it
was at the head of communications or the
head of PR for him one of the one of the
big shots on his team a verified person
on on Twitter I tweeted at him and I
said hey I'd love to have mayor Pete on
the show we'd have a great respectful
conversation hope we can work it out
within minutes the guy wrote back he
followed me on Twitter wrote back to me
said DME i DM the guy private message
him on Twitter he gives me the the email
address and then I have my team send our
formal pitch which is what we send to
everybody which tell us about the show
and the numbers in the reach and all of
those things the same professional thing
that we do with with everybody else and
we get an email back from his team
immediately they're gonna be in in LA in
June and hopefully we can work it out if
that trip is is kind of busy though and
if not that one maybe the next one then
within within an hour the mob starts
moving and you guys know all about the
mob so first it started with a writer
from Vox and then a writer from HuffPo
telling the tweeting at his guy at his
PR guy Buddha judges PR guy that they
shouldn't do the show and he just had
CERN image on and it would be a bad look
and a whole bunch of other things now
these
these are journalists journalists at
Huffington Post and Vox now I of course
I put air quotes around journalists
because these people are not journalists
they're activists what kind of
journalist sees that an interviewer
write that an interviewer wants to
interview a presidential candidate and I
think you guys all know that I would
treat mayor Pete with exactly the same
decency and respect that I treat every
single one of my guests for anyone
that's watching this even for the people
that hate me who are hate watching which
I find to be the funniest thing I think
you would agree that I have treated
every single one of my guests the same I
have never been rude to a guests I have
never tried to do a gotcha moment with a
guest I genuinely sit down I don't have
a set of intentions other other than
trying to figure out what this person
thinks figure out what our points of
agreement or disagreement are and kind
of go from there so of course I would
have an incredibly interesting
conversation with him I mean look even
the idea he happens to be a gay married
man
I'm also a gay married man how often
would you see two gay married men sit
across from each other and talk about
serious issues for an hour or even just
related to that not that I think it's so
important but you just simply don't see
that right he's not I don't know that
Anderson Cooper's married but he's not
gonna do that with Anderson Cooper so we
could have had a great interesting
political conversation but Vox and
HuffPo
journalists jump in on this they make
sure that they get a whole stream of
tweets mostly from anonymous people
saying Reubens all right and he's a
racist and all of this nonsense then
Media Matters the CEO or the president
of Media Matters
he jumps in on this too and he tells
them why he tells the judge team why
they shouldn't do my show so you've got
Media Matters
putting public pressure on a
presidential candidate not to do show
you've got journalists who are just
activists masquerading as journalists
telling people trying to put the mob on
a presidential candidate to make them
decide who or who are not there who are
who they will not talk to now what
happens well about two hours later than
that we get an email from his team that
they're not going to do it I then
subsequently responded several times I
followed up at least I think three times
completely respectfully saying I said
look I saw what happened on Twitter this
is just the our age machine
and I would treat him the way I've
treated everybody else I think we'd have
a really interesting conversation and
then they've just ignored us since then
and then his PR guy unfollowed me on
Twitter so I don't know that it ever got
to Mayor Pete right like I don't know
that he's making these decisions so I
don't want to blame him specifically
other than he is up either he made the
decision to say oh the mobs coming I'm
not gonna talk to this guy or and more
likely his team saw the mob they don't
want media matters and scary Vox and
HuffPo to go after them you know for
talking to me Dave Rubin doing his show
in his garage right they don't want to
do that and that means that he hires
people who bow to the mob so it's like
dude if you're surrounding yourself with
people who bow to the mob if that's what
your decision-making has led to those
types of people being around you well
how you gonna stand up to Trump you're
gonna stand up to Putin you're gonna
stand up to any other despot or evil
leader out there or just political
opponent out there so I kind of lost a
lot of respect for him in that regard
but I really don't want to make this
about me or even about this show it's
just like this monster that I have been
talking about that so many of my guests
have been talking about for so many
months now if not years about this
amorphis mob that all it comes around to
do is destroy people because what
they're really trying to do is they're
also trying to destroy my livelihood
it's not it's not what they're Pete does
in the show it's like all right I'd like
to have him on the show but if it
doesn't do the show that's all right
we'll get other guests I'll continue
doing a good show but what really it's
about is they want to make it so that
I'm viewed as so toxic that no one
relevant or interesting or whatever will
do the show and that that is a direct
assault not only on me as a person but
it's a direct assault on my business my
ability to you know pay my employees and
things of that nature so these are not
good people and they do this in the name
of tolerance and decency and that that's
what the crazy part of this is and the
way they throw out these terms of course
you guys know this they way they throw
out these terms of bigot and Nazi and
whatever even that that Shaun White
right you're right Shaun White Shaun
King you know Shaun King who's the the
black lives matter activist or whatever
who I guess was pretending to be black
but he's white and that whole thing
there's like yesterday he sent a tweet
at me about something about my
bigotry mine and Steven Crowder's
bigotry and it's like what are you
talking about
please show me an instance where I was
bigoted towards a group of people based
on the color of their skin or something
like that or their sexuality or their
gender it just doesn't happen but they
can just throw around these terms so
easily and that but that's also what I
mean about the hate thing it's like I
saw this tweet maybe a year ago that
might have bothered me and this time I
was just like man this is this is so sad
but it also is sort of a function of
success I guess I guess I tweet
something and then Shaun White or Shaun
King whatever his name is or like oh I'm
gonna tell all right yes maybe I happen
to be a white man pretending to be a
black man and I trade and race and I do
and I you know I've done all sorts of
he's done about a whole bunch of shady
[ __ ] it's not even worth getting into
but it's like this is this is the weird
world we live in you can just apply that
label a bigger to racist to anyone and
then you can go for their livelihood and
all of those things so I want to be very
clear about this to all of the HuffPo
Vox BuzzFeed journalists that are
watching this I will never bend the knee
and I will do what I think is right and
I will talk to the people that I want to
talk to you and maybe you will get some
success in stopping some of them from
talking to me but you won't always get
success and to quote obi-wan Kenobi if
you strike me down I will become more
powerful than you can possibly imagine
okay so that's that's a little bit on
that I want to discuss the the steven
crowder thing as well because that's
going down but do you want to mention
I'm wearing the classical liberal shirt
which we do sell in the Rubin report
store you got to do a little merch we're
trying to make up a little bit of a
youtube breath so the the Rubin reports
store the link is in the description
right down below and you can get a
classical liberal you get a classical
Reuben shirt you can get a class of a
liberal t-shirt we've got Rubin report
mugs and hoodies and stickers and caps
and and all sorts of stuff so so check
that out if you would like so along the
lines of a little of this deep
platforming thing is steven crowder who
you guys know he was on the show years
and years ago where were we at the time
I did it on skype pretty sure we were at
aura TV at the time too so he he
probably hasn't been on for about three
years I go on Crowder show maybe I don't
know three times a year
like that we have some political
disagreements and you know sometimes
with some of his humor it could be a
little a little bit over the top for me
but the guy is actually a very funny
comic I think he's running a freaking
great show and he's got something like
four million subscribers on YouTube
which despite the suppression is pretty
that's actually spectacular I don't know
how the hell he's pulling that off but
and he's doing a lot of good stuff and
he's doing actually edgy humor and all
that good stuff okay fine so he got into
it with this guy
I think his name is Carlos masa he goes
by the Twitter handle at gay wonk and
him and Crowder have been going at each
other and basically from the way I'm
understanding it right now
Carlos masa is pretty much trying to get
Crowder D platform he wants the powers
that be to get Crowder kicked off
YouTube for sort of anti LGBT stuff or
homophobia or whatever it is and it's
like a he's joking he's joking when he
does a lisp and some silly stuff
comedians are allowed to joke and by the
way you are allowed to joke about gay
people I don't know if you've ever seen
this show called Family Guy it was a
fairly popular show been on for about 20
years and the whole idea of Stewie the
baby is that he's gay I mean look at
every gay joke in that show look at
every gay joke in in the Simpsons look
at every gay joke in Seinfeld or any
great sick hum or and it's not just that
you can make gay jokes you can make
jokes about people we need jokes to
release a little bit of the steam so
that we don't start killing each other
but the reason I mentioned all of this
is because this this at gay wonk guy who
I don't know I have nothing personal
against him the only reason that I even
know the guy is this is that remember
the little Pete Buddha jej story and I
said that a Vox journalist was going at
him trying to make sure the Peabody
judge didn't do my show well guess who
it was yeah it was the same guy it was
this carlos maza guy so i don't like
talking about people specifically and i
don't care about him and don't don't
flood his twitter or any of that
nonsense and I know my audience doesn't
do that I mean that's the that's the
funny thing it's like I don't even
really have to say that because I know
if you're watching this show that
basically you hold the same relative
ideals around
see in and free speech and you don't
want to destroy people and all of that
stuff so of course I'm not I'm not
asking anybody to target this guy or
anything like that but it's like this
guy came after me and my livelihood and
now he's going after Crowder and doing
the same thing and Crowder's making
freakin jokes I think I will be on
Crowder show tomorrow by the way we're
gonna talk about that oh and speaking of
that I'm on Tucker Carlson tonight I'm
not sure what time yet if we get the
time while I'm live we'll we'll let you
know but I'll be doing Tucker and you
know Tucker's another one it's so
interesting the way this deep
platforming thing is operating because
every freaking day
there is another move to kill the
advertisers of somebody or this person
said that so let's take them out or they
talk to this person let's take him out
so you know Tucker is survived a series
of advertiser purges and I just saw that
yesterday I guess Bayer had pulled out
of his advertising for a couple months
during one of the brouhaha and mostly by
the way when these activists go after
the advertisers these people don't watch
the show in the first place I mean
that's that's the tough part of how
these corporations operate it's like you
start seeing all this Twitter anger and
these and oh my god they signed a
petition and 1500 people said Tucker's a
bad man and all of this stuff and it's
like these people don't watch your show
anyway they're just trying to take you
out but anyway I saw the Bayer I guess
started advertising again and then I saw
the usual set of journalists suddenly
trying to guilt Bayer tag Bayer and stop
them from advertising on Tucker and it's
like man these guys really hate any
oppositional thought they hate any
opposition news you know look you could
say what you want about Fox which by the
way I will not throw under the bus
because any time I go on Fox I go on I
go on Tucker probably almost once a week
now once every two weeks let's say we do
no pre-interview I don't tell them what
I'm gonna say I go on live I can say
whatever I want I've gone up there and
I've said things that I disagree with
Tucker on and some things that I agree
with them on and we just do our thing
right and what Tucker and I have I think
most in common is is the defense of free
speech at the moment so it doesn't
matter what the sort of peripheral
issues are but if you think about it
box basically is the only is really the
only sort of mainstream right-leaning
network so it's constantly piled upon
and people will say well this is what
Trump's done with the media Trump's
always attacking the media now Trump is
attacking the media all the time I think
some of its warranted obviously I think
that and some of it maybe isn't
warranted or it's over the top or maybe
just sort of not the best use of time
let's say for the President of the
United States but you know if you
remember back it's like well why
wouldn't Barack Obama attack the media
it was because the media was absolutely
in bed with him but he did attack Fox
News which was the only opposition to
him right so there is something a little
weird happening here the way that
everything is sort of framed so even
Budaj edge again as I come out Hall on
Fox a couple weeks ago and the audience
there treated him totally respectfully
they applauded at a lot of moments I
think he got a standing ovation at the
end it was totally respectful and then
the media frames it like oh even Buddha
judge gets a standing ovation at Fox
News scary right weighing conservative
evil Fox News and it's like well I could
tell you that I've been traveling the
country for the last year and I meet
conservatives and right-leaning people
everywhere who know I disagree with them
on several things some of them disagree
with very personal parts of my life
actually and I find them completely
respectful and open and decent all the
time and yet it's the people that are
constantly preaching tolerance and
diversity and telling me how wonderful
they are and how horrible everyone
else's that are often the most angry and
mean and disrespectful so it's a weird
situation we're in so anyway so I'll
talk to two Crowder about that tomorrow
but this this move to just I don't like
you so I'm gonna take you out I don't
like you so I'm gonna take you out so
one of the interesting things that was
happening to me in the last week is that
as some of the hate has been ramped up
and we we know that some of its being
coordinated by a couple people and we're
looking into ways that we can deal with
that and not that it really matters
because I could just stop looking at my
mentions or that sort of thing but you
know it's like it's all part of the game
right at some level so we're trying to
figure out what we're gonna do related
to to some of that but so I had tweeted
something last week about
that I was getting all these people just
saying awful things to me like like
hundreds if not thousands of people in
my Twitter feed you know they're 99% of
them are anonymous the council though
some of them were blue check it cannot
see you know telling me to go [ __ ]
myself and a bunch of stuff and it's
like who cares they just mute these
people you're nobody it doesn't matter
okay that's fine
and I brought it up on Twitter because
it wasn't that I wanted Twitter to stop
these people but I tweeted at Jack
Dorsey from Twitter and at Twitter
support because it's like they say
they're against targeted harassment now
we know that
why was Milo kicked off of Twitter they
supposedly because he engaged in
targeted harassment at Leslie Jones the
actress now you may believe that you may
not believe that it may be a series of
other things he may have been warned
before I mean there's a that's a whole
other story the reason I tweeted it at
Jack and at Twitter support was it's
like well I know that I'm getting
subjected to that but I guess if you're
not a full-on bowed progressive you are
allowed to get that hit so I was just
trying to show some of the hypocrisy
there so I know this is a little bit of
insider baseball stuff but it it just
really is interesting that the issues
that we've been talking about here for a
couple years now they all start they're
all really bubbling into the mainstream
and I think that's why I'm getting so
much pushback these days cuz it's like
oh I was taught like all the stuff that
I was talking about about how crazy sort
of the left had become and where are the
good liberals and you know you're
watching sort of far leftist just
ransacked the entire Democratic Party
and take away free thought and push the
platforming and all of these things now
everyone kind of sees it so you know and
I think the other thing is that you know
after I did that video on Prager you the
why I left the left video I've said this
before but I had never said I left the
left and I never even said it in that
video and when I woke up that morning I
just I didn't you know you take the way
Prager you does it is you tape the video
just sort of direct to camera like this
and then it takes a little time for them
to do the background animations and the
music and all that so it's usually I
think was maybe to two or three months
later that the video went up I get a
notification I'm laying in bed I get a
notification and you should not have
your phone by your bed that is something
I'm really trying not to do but I was
doing it at that time and it said
something like new Praeger you video
Dave Rubin why I left the left and I was
like [ __ ] you know I never said that I
the left and I had really felt that for
a couple years it had been sort of my
job or at least my mission to kind of
fix the left from the inside I always
considered myself a liberal and a lefty
and all of those things and and for a
long time a progressive and I was
addressing the issues around free speech
and all the labeling and all that that I
think was was wrong with the left and I
thought yeah I want to do this from the
inside because this is my side and I
want to clean up so I was really
actually upset when that video went up
and I did I might have even email Denis
immediately not I can't remember exactly
I think I emailed somebody over at
Prague RIA because I was considering
asking them to change the title and then
within an hour so I saw that the video
was doing so well that it seemed to be
catching something else that maybe I
couldn't quite see and that it was
actually important in a way to say that
I left the left that I was this and this
thing went so crazy that it took a good
decent open-minded liberal and it the
only way to fix it was to walk away from
it now so this is one of the interesting
things that's happening there's been a
lot of criticism of the IDW right now
and I want to get into some of the some
of that actually but I think one of the
the sort of the crux is of what's
happening right now is that I see a sort
of I see a sort of general split in in
some of the IDW crew now for those of
you that don't know the IDW of course
this is the intellectual dark web which
really in my view is just a loosely
associated group of academics and
authors and thinkers and comedians and
podcasters and bunch of people that just
were having relevant interesting
conversations on YouTube and podcast and
obviously this includes Joe Rogan and
Sam Harris and Jordan Peterson and the
weinstein brothers and Douglas Mari and
Christina Hoff Sommers and and the list
goes on there was never there was never
a laminated card handed out in a secret
handshake where you get together in a
secret Club we never had that right so
this was just sort of a loosely
affiliated interesting group of people
that were truly some of them were
pro-choice some of them were pro-life we
had conservatives like Ben Shapiro and
and lefties like Brett Weinstein and we
were just kind of talking this stuff out
and basically we could agree to disagree
we could agree on what the basic sort of
fundamental foundation of what a
conversation was and and that type of
thing then that article came out in the
New York Times which is a little over
a year ago now and it sort of really
tried to set the parameters on who you
can or can't talk to so there's a moment
in that article which was written by
Barry Weiss in the New York Times where
she said and I just tweeted out a little
clip of Joe Rogan and I discussing this
where she says that basically if you
talk to people like she mentions mics
erna bitching stefan molyneux
specifically that you'd be cynical or
stupid in effect and that really to me
in the article was a shot at me and
Rogan because as the interviewers we're
gonna talk to an eclectic group of
people right he's gonna talk to Alex
Jones I'm gonna talk to Mike Serna [ __ ]
etc etc that's what interviewers do
that's what Larry King my my mentor and
one of the best people on planet earth
and the greatest interviewer of all time
talk to all sorts of interesting on
sometimes evil people I mean he you know
I always say this it's like if you think
of Larry King try to think of Siena in
1991 like the peak of Larry King it's
like he would have like the OJ Simpson
defense team you know or maybe that was
before 1991 so like 1995 let's say Larry
King he'd have you know the OJ Simpson
defense team on on Monday he'd have the
cast of friends on on Tuesday he'd have
the animals zoo guy with the monkey on
his head and a snake wrapped around his
neck on Wednesday he'd have you know
Magic Johnson on on Thursday and then he
would have Desmond Tutu on on Friday
right and it's like nobody thought he
endorsed all these ideas or liked or
disliked all of these people or anything
but there's something because of the
more relaxed atmosphere I think that
that I've created here that say Rogan is
created in his studio that some of the
other podcasters have created that if
you actually sit down with someone and
you treat them like a human like you
know like a decent respectful human then
people think that you're you're somehow
endorsing all of those ideas I mean
while CNN can interview you know the
foreign minister or Martha Raddatz just
the other day I think from ABC News
interviewed the foreign minister of Iran
we know he's funding Hamas it's like all
right did she just launder his ideas
nobody seems to be upset about that I
don't even like making it about this
tit-for-tat thing but there's just this
there's just this odd way of looking at
all this stuff but anyway what I think
one of the interesting things happening
right now with the IDW is that there's
going to be
a certain split along the lines of what
I just talked about that
I think most of the IDW people came from
the left and I would say this is pretty
much true of everyone I think except for
Shapiro who pretty much has always been
a conservative but even Jordan Peterson
who's you know I would say a little more
traditionally conservative now I think
he was someone that came of the left I
mean came up through academia and all of
that but certainly the weinstein
brothers in sam harris and me and
whoever it is right it's like most of
these people either are lefties or were
lefties or have been purged from left or
whatever so what I think the interesting
crux and now there's been a lot of
articles written about this lately is
that what is this thing is it can
something be just sort of a loosely
affiliated group of people that some are
going to talk to some people you don't
like some are gonna operate this way
some are gonna some are gonna be more
politically incorrect because they're
comedians some are gonna be very
academic because they're from the world
of academia can you attend that loose
association and that crazy you know
connective thing can that actually exist
with a truly diverse set of ideas
sometimes bordering on some dangerous
ideas can that exist and I think it can
or do you really have to gate keep
around it so that you make sure that
none of those danger more more dangerous
I don't even like that word but though
that those more Fringe ideas don't get
out there so what I think is interesting
right now is that and this relates it to
the why I left the left video is that
it's become very obvious like my
frustrations me right now just Dave 2019
my frustrations are more obviously with
the modern left you guys know what I
think about social justice I believe in
true justice I believe in true equality
I believe in true Liberty in that we
should have individual rights for
everyone everyone in a country
regardless of race or gender or
sexuality or body parts or any of those
things should have exactly the same
rights you should not have special
treatment for anyone because if you say
that oh this group of people based on
the color of their skin or their gender
should have special rights or special
access or get more well that can
sometimes sound good right we want to
help these people but what that means is
you have to take from someone else and
you have to actually punish
but he else so the best like simplest
example of this would be something like
what happened at Harvard where they
actually deflated and depressed the
amount of Asians asian-americans that
could get into Harvard because they fell
too many Asians were getting in there
now no one gave Asian people anything as
they came to America whether they came
from Korea or from Japan or from China I
mean look if you're Asian or if you know
anything about any asian-americans
history it's like it's the same
immigrant history that everybody had
what most people who are successful
today let's say in their 20s or 30s or
40s their grandparents or
great-grandparents came from nothing
often faced discrimination had to work
crappy jobs all of those things so that
their children could go from lower class
to middle class so that the next
generation could maybe could go to
upper-middle class and that hopefully
the next generation can go even beyond
that and that's the same immigrant story
that almost everyone has in the United
States but it wasn't because oh they
gave Asian people this and that's what
made them successful it actually it was
because of the reverse we didn't give
any of these immigrant groups anything
that we did have strong stronger
education back then than we do now and I
think there's some interesting ways that
that can be talked about and that's why
I'm for school choice and charter
schools and a whole bunch of other
things which by the way the left is not
for but the point is what Harvard was
doing is intentionally depressing the
amount of Asian students because they
work really hard they focus on family
and education in school and we you know
Tiger mom I've had Amy Chua in here and
all of those things and it's like you're
actually discriminating based on an
immutable characteristic the race of the
applicant and not only so that means
you're gonna punish this Asian student
right who worked really hard who's you
have no idea what he's come from right
he stood he actually might be poor he
might be wealthy and his parents you
know it's it's like all of those things
they don't even matter didn't get the
grades to get into this school is he of
the worth of what a Harvard attendee
should be and if you say well because
he's Asian we're not gonna let him in it
because we want to let in more black
people or we want to let in more this
person or that person were gay people or
whatever so stupid it's like okay well
now you've let in people who weren't
necessarily qualified because you took
the most qualified person and you said
okay most qualified person you can't
come in because we want more people
based on skin color or whatever to get
in
well now you've someone who's less
qualified to get in now of course if
someone was equally qualified then they
have to decide if you have an equally
qualified asian person and black person
and white person whatever it is well
then they have to figure out what who'd
had more extracurricular work or who was
on a better sports team or it no it's a
series of leverage that they have to
push to figure out who they want to let
in but once you let in someone at a
lower class well now you've actually
depressed what the academic value of the
school is and then what you say is okay
now that person gets out well then do
they if let's say they have less
positive grades at the end of four years
well now do you let them get into grad
school with less because of the color of
their skin or their sexuality and then
after that do they get a job because of
the color of their skin or their
sexuality I mean it just it really none
of this really stands to reason and
we've we've really got to fight this
stuff because what's happening is the
same people who will tell you that there
is systemic racism meaning that the
system itself is racist that there are
racist laws which by the way there are
no racist laws it doesn't mean that
racism doesn't exist because racism does
exist it's part of the human condition
and there are always gonna be bigots and
there's always gonna be people who don't
like minorities and there's always gonna
be people who don't like majorities -
right I mean my you know hating white
people you can get on Twitter get a blue
check and you could talk about hating
white people all day long and love you
for it right it's not
that's all good apparently to these
people but we've got to figure out a way
to talk about these things very
seriously and very honestly so okay so
bringing this back to where I started
for me look I see those set of ideas the
I see intersectionality and the
oppression Olympics and judging based on
the color of skin and immutable
characteristics I see that as the
greatest threat to the American
experiment that there is I see that as
far more of a threat than Donald Trump I
see that as the type of thing that would
literally turn neighbor against neighbor
it would turn wife against husband it
would it's the reverse of how the whole
system was set up it was it's the
reverse of the melting pot which means
you come from all parts of the world and
you bring in your traditions but but you
sort of fold into the fabric of America
we've done that better here than
anywhere else which is why we don't have
the integration problems
that they have throughout Europe and all
over the world we've done it better here
go on a New York City subway I mean
really go on a New York City subway you
look around and you will see everybody
from every part of the world everybody
looks equally miserable and it's hot and
it's smelly and it's gross and nobody
wants you to touch them or anything like
that but guess what we're not killing
each other there because this experiment
has worked so all of the people that
really want to undo this experiment most
likely they're going to lead to an
experiment that's very dangerous so look
that is a set of ideas that has really
been absorbed by the modern left I think
that set of ideas is obviously very bad
and very dangerous
and sort of has to be destroyed so that
the so that the modern left can change
into something that is that returns to
liberalism right that returns to JFK ask
not what my country can do for me or ask
not what my country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country that's
not what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country
right I don't have to doing a lot of
talking lately it's a lot of talking
that's that's 180 the different the
reverse of what Bernie would say Bernie
would say we want to give you free
health care we want to give you free
education and all of these things ask
what the government can do for you don't
ask what you can do for your fellow man
right and that that's a huge difference
if Bernie got on stage and said that
thing that JFK a Liberal Democrat said
in the late 60s it's like he would be
treated very poorly for that right JFK
who was anti-war who was wanted to cut
taxes who did cut taxes and a whole
bunch of other things so it's like I
want that type of liberalism to return
now it is my belief that by showing
people that you can walk away from the
left you can walk away for less than
what you will find by and large is that
conservatives are pretty decent people
on the right are pretty decent
libertarians by particularly like
libertarians but like there's a set of
people that are constantly that you're
constantly told or horrible and racist
and all of these things we just actually
aren't and who are willing to agree to
disagree and all sorts of stuff and so
my belief is that a certain set of
people have to have to walk away for
that thing to change now I think what
some of the other IDW
ri-ight IDW people believe so I would
say maybe this is like Brett Weinstein
for example I don't want to speak for
him but I would say basically his belief
is we can kind of fix the left from the
inside now I was kind of trying to do it
for years and I saw no traction and if
anything I've seen it get consistently
worse which is why it's in the state
that it's in right now if Brett turns
out to be right and there's some magical
way that the Liberals can somehow stop
the far left ease and the progressives
from just sort of wrecking the
Democratic Party and just decimating the
whole thing well I'll gladly if Brett
comes to me one day he's like Dave
you're not gonna believe this but we did
it I can't believe it I will be like wow
that is absolutely incredible and
whether at this point I want to be part
of that or I want to be part of a a
right let's say that's that's modifying
and moderating and and seemingly about
ideas which is what I see now well
that's a great discussion to have and I
have no doubt that Brett and I can have
that discussion but I do see this as an
interesting distinction sort of what's
going on with the IDW because I'm sure a
whole bunch of you saw that Collette
recently and now Clara Lehmann who's the
editor of quad the founder and editor of
quad has been on this show she's on this
show maybe I don't know maybe six or
eight months ago or so I just saw her in
Australia when I was there with Jordan
Peterson I've had dinners with her
they've run a series of pieces basically
trying to say that anyone who leans to
the right really kind of can't be in the
IDW or that you're if you talk to a
certain set of people you camp in the
IDW and really most of that is aimed at
me they always use my picture they show
a picture of me smiling with with tucker
carlson and you know that were partisan
Claire Claire tweeted something to the
effect that I'm partisan and that I'm a
baby
and a bunch of other stuff now the
people that they're criticizing me for
having on the show so I'm talking about
Stefan Molyneux and Mike Serna [ __ ] and
Lauren southern and Paul Joseph Watson I
think those are the four I had all four
of those people on the show before I had
Claire on so she could have sat in that
chair right there I mean we don't edit
for content so if I had known she had
any issues with any of the people I've
had on the show or the ways that I've
conducted those interviews or if she
thought that I didn't ask questions
properly or anything she could have said
that to my face
literally in this room on the show or
she could have messaged me privately
about it or said it to me at a dinner
we've been to or anything like that but
instead they've just run a series of
pieces about it now ironically and the
reason I went sort of slightly bananas
on Twitter last week even though Twitter
is not real life and it really isn't was
because the author of the one last week
was Cathy young and Cathy young also was
a guest on this show and she was a guest
on this show after I had Serna [ __ ] on
the original time I'm not sure where it
was related to the other guys know you
know what it was after I had Serna Mitch
and Paul Joseph Watson on I'm a hundred
percent sure of that so and by the way
Cathy Young has been on stage with Milo
and not Gavin McGinnis and Serena [ __ ]
and a bunch of these other guys and what
I think she was really doing there and
again I don't like to make this about
people because I'd rather talk about
ideas so I'm not talking about her
specifically but what she in essence was
trying to do was they can see it there's
a movement right now to really take the
idea IDW and sort of brand that is
something that can fix the left I just
don't I just personally don't believe
that but as I said maybe I'm wrong and
if I am wrong that'll be a great ending
to this thing too right I'll eat some
crow it's all good okay but what she's
trying to do I think by throwing me
under the bus
Reuben talks to these people or he
didn't ask this question the way I
wanted to be that question another way
it's like it's offering herself a little
cover because she knows she's come to
those people so it's like make a very
public spectac
spectacle and throwing this guy under
the bus so you think you'll get yourself
a little cover now of course it won't
hurt that's the way this thing up right
you can't feed the beast enough the
Beast is still hungry and wants to come
and get more people so I think it's
pretty short sighted by her but what I
was really annoyed about was it wasn't
even the article specifically actually
and and the article I think if I'm not
mistaken upon a Friday or at least I
think I saw it on a Friday you guys know
I don't tweet on the weekends so I saw
it just as I was about to get offline
and I was like yeah you know what this
sucks cuz it's like I've had this woman
on the show she begged repeatedly to
come on the show she wanted me to fly
her out here she was asking me to
connect her with all these guests and
all this stuff but I treated her exactly
the same way as I've treated everybody
else and all of this look we're good we
got a microphone thing how we doing how
we doing good yeah we're good okay sorry
about the little
Audio thing there anyway what was
disappointing it's like I've had these
people on the show some and then I saw a
few other people that have been former
guests of mine I'm not even gonna get
into their names kind of jump on the
pile on people who have literally been
here for dinner my cut my husband has
cooked some of these people at dinner
and they're jumping in on it too and
it's like forget me forget the show but
what is happening to a general sense of
civility let's say you'd knew so let's
say you had a coworker I mean you just
think about yourself for a second try to
think of a co-worker someone that you
kinda like you don't have to love them
you don't have to hate them just someone
that you just kind of work with every
now and again who hasn't done it wrong
to you in any way
okay so just someone that you work with
let's say you had some issue it's
something that they did something that
they did at work they either didn't do
something properly or you were confused
as to why they did something or whatever
it is what do you think the right thing
to do would be would it be to that you'd
maybe pull them well first you could
send them an email you can send them a
text message you could pull them aside
at lunch have a private conversation
with them and discuss those things or
would it be that you would immediately
go to the public execution of them and
jump on the pile on and that's what
bothered me more and that's why I was
kind of annoyed last week because it was
like when it's people that you know it's
not like so some Shaun King or whatever
it's like I don't know you we're never
gonna cross paths I don't I have no
respect for you it doesn't matter
so it was like laughs that way I said
that funny tweet about it but like that
was it but when people know you and do
those things it really does tell you
that the state of conversation does seem
to be dysregulated right now and and
maybe maybe dangerously dysregulated
because I don't think that inherently
these are bad people but everyone sort
of gets in on the click machine so so
anyway I was I was disappointed by that
I suspect cool that's gonna kind of keep
going with this thing and just for the
record Claire did I I reached out to
Claire privately a couple times she
finally did respond and she offered that
I could do their podcast so I guess
quill out has a podcast now and they
would they would offer me to issue a
rebuttal if I would sit down with one of
their people and do their podcast and
it's like I said her I was like you know
you used me once for to come in here
four clicks for yourself and that's fine
like we're all doing things to get
publicity so we can build whatever it is
that we're all individually building but
it's like you use me once in my own
studio then you write these hip pieces
about me because you you see that it's
like an easy target or I don't know
something I've hit some level that you
want to come after me whatever it is
doesn't matter but I'm not going to now
do your podcast so I can help you build
your podcast audience - so I had had a
writer for couette who will remain
unnamed offered to do a print interview
with me and I completely accepted and
Claire said no they're not they're not
going to do that they only want to do it
on the podcast so that's sort of the
state of where that they're at I may do
a print thing or I may write something
for another website although I think
I've explained myself here but anyway
it's just it's just sort of like little
little sort of annoying things to think
about but there's just the whole the
whole ecosystem is in flux right now
which is actually pretty cool like as
long as people aren't getting killed and
as long as people you know aren't being
silenced and all of those things then
it's all good but I didn't I think I
learned a little bit of a lesson for
myself last week it's like I know it
intellectually but I think maybe I
needed to learn it sort of at a personal
level which is just that you can't when
you hit somewhere you get to some level
like they're just gonna come they're
just gonna come in and by responding all
the time you're just gonna amplify it
it's like throwing a gremlin in water
and then they're just gonna multiply and
multiply because oh they got your
attention they got your attention so I
saw some other article going after me
today I'm just like alright alright so
that that's kind of where we're at and
that's what I said before it's like
oddly that has become a measure of
success rather than just doing shows
that I'm satisfied with and and you know
meeting you guys and and all that other
stuff so you know there's some
interesting interesting stuff going on
man I've been talking that's a lot of
talking hold on just a second
okay so let's just shift from show stuff
for a second because I wanted to mention
something that I haven't talked about on
YouTube or on the podcast but if you're
paying attention on Twitter or Instagram
has been going on so in February I was I
think around for a 21st or so
I had just come back from Australia and
I was taking a few days with my family
my folks and my brother and sister and
kids in in Florida and we got a call
from my sister-in-law who was here
house-sitting watching our dog that our
dog Emma that there was some blood in
her pee and she was going to have a vet
come to the house and take a look at her
and within a day or two we found out
that she had or has pretty advanced
bladder cancer which is pretty rare in
dogs actually it's not it's not a common
cancer in dogs unless she had a pretty
big tumor in her bladder and that was
causing her to urinate more and it was
also it caused like a little fissure
basically in the bladder and that was
causing blood to me in the urine and all
that this is about three months ago so
when we got back immediately you know I
didn't know if they had told us that it
was advanced so I didn't know if we had
no time left if we were just about to
say goodbye to her that I've told this a
couple of times but Emma is she's 15
years old she's a rescue from Hurricane
Katrina in New Orleans she gave birth
during the hurricane they found her in a
box she eventually was you know the dogs
were sent all over the country I have
adopted her on June 22nd 2006 in New
York City the hurricane was in August or
September of 2005 so he was so sick that
basically for six months could it be
adopted her dog her puppies got adopted
immediately walking her one day in
Central Park I think this was first or
second day I had her and this woman
comes up to me and says is that Paisley
from the Humane Society so Paisley
because Emma's had three names she had a
name in New Orleans because they found
her with the collar with no tags so we
don't know what that name was the Humane
Society that names her Emma
sorry names her Paisley and then we
named her Emma so this woman comes up
and says that Paisley from the Humane
Society and I was like they only have 12
or 14 dogs at a time so I was like yeah
she said well this is her son Bernard
and she somehow recognized her and they
got together and they sniffed but like
only a mother and child could and then
we lost touch with with the woman and
then a few months ago when this whole
thing happened when we found out about
Eman cancer I long Twitter thread with a
whole bunch of pictures of Emma and we
were able to reconnect with the woman
who I met in Central Park whose name is
Amy Stanton she's actually in PR here
Los Angeles and it turns out she only
lives about 15 minutes away and we got
Emma and her long-lost son Bernard
together we've now done it twice we got
them together on Mother's Day and and
it's been a pretty beautiful thing so
anyway so when we found out that Emma
had cancer you know we took her all the
doctors and everything and we realized
that 15 years old it's like we're not
gonna we're not gonna put her through
you know there's chemo there's
operations there's there's all sorts of
stuff that they can do that that's
grueling and you're extending time and
and even putting the money aside it's
like what's the point what's the point
at that age but they were willing to do
it I mean we met with the oncologist and
all the people and all that and we
decided to just go a completely other
route which is we've put her on CBD so
that's medicinal marijuana we have her
on a mushroom blend because there's a
bunch of mushroom powders that they say
have anti-cancer effects we put her on
all organic not dog food diet so like
organic chicken from Whole Foods chopped
up freshly cooked with some potato and
sometimes some vegetables and she's been
going now for they told us that she
probably have like 2 to 5 months
something like that and that even if you
have chemo and you're young and do it
that you really only have 10 months
we're almost four months in now and
she's doing great she's lost some weight
she looks good she feels good I tweet
out some videos of her running around
you know she gets she's getting vitamin
B shots we she's had acupuncture because
she's also got arthritis I got a lot of
hate I took a picture of her with some
acupuncture needles in and it doesn't
really bother her you know she kind of
stands still but she's not she's not in
pain she's not writhing or anything but
you know it's not the most comfortable
thing for any of you that have had
acupuncture there I get it every now and
again I know a lot of you gonna say it's
the placebo effect it's the bleep oh
okay whatever
the point is that with her arthritis we
noticed that her she was having trouble
sitting her legs in the back we're kind
of getting crossed which is an issue
that dogs have with their hips and when
she gets the acupuncture I mean
literally she had it done two or three
weeks ago that morning she was really
having trouble kind of walking straight
because the back legs were kind of
crossed up so when she'd walked she'd be
kind of just veering one way or the
other
she gets the acupuncture and immediately
she can walk fine and then that lasts
for weeks so you could tell me it's
placebo if
you can tell me it's nonsense you can
tell me you don't believe in Eastern
medicine you tell me whatever you want
but I can tell you what I'm seeing here
and that it's actually working so anyway
it's been like a really it's been
cathartic and it's been sort of a human
thing like at the amount of people I
mean I've had I've had hundreds if not
thousands you guys sending me pictures
of your older dogs or dogs that you've
lost or cats or Turtles or whatever and
like that that human animal bond it's
pretty cool and and you know it's also
nice you know it's like in life you
don't know whether it's an animal or or
a person or a family member or friend
whatever it is you know you don't know
when someone's just gonna be taken away
from you just like that you know car
accidents you know sudden medical thing
or whatever it is and it's like to have
some time where it's like oh you know
your time is limited but it's not you
know watching some someone or an animal
just be miserable or in pain or whatever
knowing that you did everything you
could do to maximize the amount of time
you have together has been pretty pretty
awesome so so we've been we've been
going through that at the same time I
have been writing my book which I know
I've been writing forever and many of
you keep asking me so here is the story
on the book we are officially pig picked
up by one of the big publishers I can't
say it yet however the the book
announcement will be on August 1st that
is when they will announce the title of
my book the cover which I'm super
excited to show you guys we've got a
whole bunch of mock-ups here I'm about a
hundred pages into the book out of about
250 I'm trying to have it done the due
date is technically August 1st now when
you get a due date in these contracts
usually got about a 30-day window but
you guys know I go off the grid in
August and I'll talk about that in a
second so my due date is August 1st I'm
really trying to have this thing done by
July 1st so we're at the beginning of
June now so there's gonna be a crazy
month I only have one or two traveling
things this month I'll probably take one
day off for my birthday on June 26 but
that that basically is it and really
just focusing in on the book and it's
also been helping me refine my idea
and try to try to you know we all get
caught I think a little bit or at least
if you're in this space I think you get
caught in sort of the day-to-day
operations this person said this today
this happened right now and we have to
comment and this now the other thing but
when you're writing a book you want it
to be something timeless you want it to
be something that that is as relevant
five years from when it's published as
the day that it's published so I think
it's really helped me sort of get all my
ideas in order I don't want to say too
much of what it's about however I think
you guys can suspect when it's kind of
about I mean it's definitely a little
bit about my political evolution and
sort of the way I see the world sort of
going at the moment you know so it'll be
out in May of 2020 so August 1st it'll
be announced the website will be up
they'll be it you'll be we'll be able to
take pre-orders I've already got a
pretty cool collected group of people
that are writing you know stuff on the
back and we got somebody big who I can't
mention to write the foreword so there's
there's a yeah feeling good about that's
the thing it's like some of the hate
stuff comes in and you know I can't say
that it doesn't affect me at all because
sometimes there's like a couple hours
where I'm like man it's like for all of
the goodness and I built this thing in
my in my home and you know I've got a
good life and all of those things it's
like sometimes the hate really can
rattle through you it really can oh and
you know speaking of the hate so lurid
southern who is one of the four people
who I mentioned earlier about these four
people that are thought of as my four
most controversial interviews I don't
know that anyone was ever hurt because
of these interviews if anything when
I've put these people on and I don't
mean Lauren specifically if their ideas
are bad just like any of my other guests
the ideas will be exposed to be bad and
then then that's what it is okay
but interestingly when when Cathy young
wrote this piece about me a couple days
ago Lauren southern sort of jumped to my
defense and said and tweeted at Cathy
that Cathy had done some sort of what
she described as sort of unethical
journalistic related things to her and
that they used to be friends and Cathy
threw under the bus and a whole bunch of
other stuff and Lauren Lauren even sent
me an email exchange which obviously she
didn't want to share publicly and I
didn't want to but but without getting
into the weeds Lauren was telling the
truth about the exchange with Cathy and
it was unfortunate to see Cathy just
keep keep jumping in but we know this is
what these guys do they
always double down always double down
always double down it never stopped
I mentioned this because just was it
yesterday I think maybe it was the day
before yesterday
Lauren whether you love Lauren her hate
Lauren or whatever else I I found her to
be very respectful and interesting and
you know I haven't seen all of her stuff
if she's done some more untoward stuff
but I don't want to make it about that
she announced you know in a blog post
that she's stepping away from public
life altogether and probably gone back
to school she wrote her really
I thought heartfelt honest decent piece
basically that this can be tough being
in the public eye especially in the
political space these days because you
watch your friends in this case Kathy
was a former friend of hers as she said
in the tweet she had spent far more time
with Kathy than she ever spent with me I
only met her I met her when she did my
show and one other time for about two
minutes but when you watch you know
people that you think you trust and like
and that her friends with turn on you
and all of these things she really wrote
this interesting thing about how how
difficult this all can be and she's
totally stepping away from public life
and it doesn't matter whether I agree
with her on everything or disagree with
her on everything or somewhere in
between which is obviously where it
really is it's like man you know people
self-selecting out of this I know how
many of you guys you a lot of you guys
watch these shows and probably identify
with me because you can't speak about
these things in your real life or not
that you can you feel that you can you
feel that if you mention these ideas at
work whatever it might be or if you
mention these ideas to your family to
your spouse and your friends you're
gonna be ostracized and all of these
things and that's such an unfortunate
and disappointing what a way of living
and yet I understand why you guys do it
and the weird thing is that I don't
think I am particularly brave or unique
or any of those things I think for some
reason I am willing to do this or for
some reason I started doing it and then
the path just kept moving and kept
widening and I just kept doing it but
you know it's like we need more people
to jump in and start fighting some of
the forces what look I may be more
frustrated with some of the
left but it doesn't mean that their that
everything on the right is great I think
they've done a better job of policing
themselves and you know there there's
some interesting debates on the future
of conservatism and where and
libertarianism fits on that there's some
really interesting stuff going on there
and they're not they're not purging out
people just because they disagree with
them they're actually having some
interesting fights so what we need
really more than anything else is for
more of you to just start saying what
you think you know I go to these college
campuses and kids always ask it it comes
up at every single college event that
there is they ask well I want to get a
grade you know my teachers teaching
postmodern left is I like it could be
about they're not even in history
classes or politic classes it's like I'm
in an art class and my tip my teacher is
pushing identity politics down my throat
or diversity or any of the other buzz
things in the day and I just want to get
the grade because I want to get into
grad school and I want to get the job
things and it's like well Jordan talks
about this and I think he does a loosely
quote him in a far less eloquent way but
one of the things that Jordan talks
about is that if you're in college and
you write a paper not because you
believe it but because you want to get
the grade well let's say you do that
when you're a freshman and it's gonna be
pretty pretty easy pretty hard for you
to do the first time right because it's
like oh you know it's nobody likes
saying things that they know not to be
true just for the for the sort of hope
of a future reward or something like
that
but each time that you do it it will get
subsequently easier until the point come
where you're gonna be a senior you're
not even gonna remember that person who
was a freshman who who was stronger and
younger and had more will to fight the
power and fight the world in all of
those things so it's like the more that
we all do that we all just kind of
forget who we are and we forget those
principles in the first place and that
sort of is the the slow sort of road to
perhaps where we're at right now so we
just need more people when kids okay I
was call my kids but with college
students ask me this question my answer
is like well alright what could I tell
you right now like they'll be like what
should I do
and it's like imagine if I said to you
alright you know what just keep keep
doing the things you don't think true
don't don't fight
be quiet now you know you're not gonna
magically get braver right you're not
gonna be out of college you're gonna be
like oh I've got a mortgage and a dog
and a wife and uh and car payments and
you know got to deal with insurance and
a gajillion other things now I'm gonna
tell the world what I think it's just
not gonna happen it's just not gonna
happen so whatever stage you're at right
now if you've got you know it doesn't
mean it doesn't mean just go out you
know like guns blazing and and like take
out everybody and like you know
absolutely saying what you think at
every moment of the day and feel that
you're all your co-workers have to
listen to you rant and rave and all of
those things but if you can push out
some of these ideas or that or sometimes
when you're out of business lunch and
maybe they're there babbling on about
how great diversity is and you know that
it's not real diversity it's photo or
see that there might be ways you can say
certain things and I I suspect that you
will feel better about yourself and then
if more people start doing it then more
people around them start kind of waking
up around these ideas and all these
things so I hope that that's what people
are gonna do basically and I I think I
think that maybe we're getting there you
know it's gonna be a weird we got a
weird year-and-a-half coming right like
you know this summer rolls into
presidential debates already which think
how crazy that is like doesn't it feel
like just yesterday we were gone through
the Trump Hillary thing and now we're
about to start the Democratic debates
it's like oh god everything has become
so extended these extended long crazy
things it's it's a lot it's a lot to to
deal with but I think that if we if all
of us just start saying what we think a
little bit more because I don't think
most of you were racist I don't think
most of you were bigots I don't think
most people in the United States or
anywhere in the West are any of these
things and we've acquiesced a lot of our
a lot of our our intellectual debate to
people who would love to silence us and
that's it that's a bad move because
they're never gonna give back the right
to say what you think they'll gladly
take it but they ain't gonna give it
back so so before I wrap up here with
all that in mind
so my goal is to have the book done by
July 1st that way I have a month because
I want to try to enjoy a little bit of
the summer so that way I have a month in
July where I'll do the back and forth
with the edits and then I've already
told you know the the the team behind
the book I've already told them I'm
gonna disappear for August I've done the
last two August off the grid that is no
phone no TV no news no nothing it's very
hard to avoid CNN because wherever there
is a muted TV in the world whether it's
a airport or a burger joint or a bowling
alley if there's a muted TV there is CNN
so it can be very hard to avoid that and
go to the gym and I had to like do
cardio with like this the whole time
because I didn't want to see TVs but I
was able to do it and I'm going to issue
a challenge I'm gonna publicly issue
this challenge to a couple other people
a couple other people in my circle but I
want to issue this challenge to you guys
too so I'm just putting this out here as
a floater for now I want to see how many
people can actually take August off like
really do it now I get it
you might mean your phone like there
were a couple times I when I was away
for a portion of it I actually did lock
my phone and it safe then there were
moments where I like I had to like pick
up people at the airport so I needed GPS
or like a few things like that but made
sure not to check my emails and
certainly not checked Twitter or
Instagram or any of that kind of stuff
so I don't mean that everyone has to go
off the grid meaning lock your phone
away in a safe but what if a whole bunch
of us what if a couple thousand of us
actually all try to do this at the same
time and then report back to each other
you know
actually report back to each other on
you know how did it feel how did you
feel did you feel more patient where you
were you nicer to people in real life
did your brain have a have a little
break did you did you feel decent you
know like really do that so I'm gonna
issue that challenge to a couple of
public people but I hope some of you
guys will consider doing it as well and
and if you look if I get a people of all
sorts of different considerations and if
you have kids you may need your phone
more and all different things but maybe
if people could take a week off or if
you could take some weekends off or some
of that I don't know just try to I think
we can reset some of this into something
that feels a little bit better maybe
then it then it feels right now okay
there was one other thing that I wanted
to tell you oh so with all that in mind
and obviously the theme here has been
about sort of the platforming and
conversation all that so as you guys
know Jordan Peterson and I we left
patreon back in December and that was
shortly after
carl benjamin sargon of akkad had been
kicked off a patreon for saying the
n-word except he didn't even say it on
his platform not only not he didn't even
say it on his youtube channel he said it
on a third-party YouTube channel he also
didn't say the n-word in a pejorative
way he was saying it to mock the people
who use language like that but patreon
booted him and Jordan Peterson and I and
Sam Harris we all left patreon because
we just felt this they're not respecting
free speech in a way that we think is
okay now look we get it that all of
these platforms have booted different
people and it's like we all can't cancel
all out of our accounts on all of these
things we need some modes of
communication to get to you guys right
YouTube's done some shady stuff I can't
shut down YouTube tomorrow but what we
did promise you so we left and for me
when we left patreon was about 70% of my
company's revenue now we got several
full timers we got several part-timers I
don't think a normal person a normal
business person and maybe I guess I'm
just not would voluntarily give up 70%
of their company's revenue but we
decided to push everybody to our website
and I'm happy to report actually that by
going to Dave remain calm / donate we
got a huge percentage of you guys to
come over and our revenue actually
bumped up a nice amount because I think
there's a real bravery deficit out there
in the world right now and if you show a
little bravery I will do something that
puts me at risk to do something because
I think it is the right thing to do I'm
thrilled and elated and honored and
humbled to say that you guys supported
me along the way so we moved all of our
support over there which by the way it
was also good for us because then we cut
out the middleman so we didn't have to
give patreon a percentage of that so
it's Dave Rubin Khan / donate if you'd
like to jump in which right now the only
reward we offer right now I mean you're
supporting the show period because as
you know the YouTube Rev is freaking
mess and the rest of it so you're
supporting the show that's the number
one thing
there is also an ad-free podcast there
so if you don't want to listen to ads
anymore on the podcast we have an
ad-free podcast feed but more
importantly than that one of the things
that Jordan and I talked about we did a
couple live streams that you may
remember just some Google hangout stuff
about what some of the solutions are and
everyone's talking about this now I mean
I went on Drudge today and the lead is
now that the government starting to get
involved
tech companies so there's a lot of
movement in this space and over the past
couple months we have had conversation
female me that they have the solution
how to decentralize and use box chain
and you know Victorian video this and
audio that and you know blah blah blah
blah blah we took all sorts of meetings
I mean this was on top of writing my
book and traveling and everything else
suddenly I was felt like I was like a
tech guru basically but Jordan and I
have been working on something for quite
some time and we're trying to figure out
exactly how that's going to be launched
and Jordan has some personal stuff going
on at the moment that some of you guys
may may know about and I'm sure he'll
address publicly at some point but it's
not my place to to get into that so
we're sort of in a little bit of a
holding pattern on that I can also tell
you that I started another tech company
a couple weeks ago we just got some nice
investment and we're building something
that I think is a real truly truly truly
a real answer to a lot of this stuff and
we've got some good people with the
right the right minds behind us to help
do this so I guess I'm heading up
another company in the midst of all this
if I didn't have enough to do so what I
think will happen is that product which
we're building right now my hope is to
have that debuted the day I come back in
September there'll be a couple things
that happen before then and we're
working on some other distribution stuff
that I kind of hinted at last week I
don't mean to be so sort of cryptic or
evasive about all these things but it's
sort of like I'm just kind of letting
you guys know like the all these things
are in the works and things you know a
lot of people get very impatient oh you
and Jordan said you were gonna have
something and it's like it's three
months later and it's like it all take
everything takes time whatever you're
doing whether you're building a platform
whether you're building an app whether
you're doing anything in this space like
it's not even just about physically
building these things it's not about
just building the tech you know figuring
out terms of service making sure the
payment processors don't take you down
make sure that you know there aren't
legal issues and what happens if you
know someone says something in India
that they're not allowed or Pakistan
that they're not allowed to say on your
American platform and all of those
things and what if you put on a lot of
people that have been deep platformed on
the other platforms and then the big
tech guys come after you to like we just
have to think all of these things
through and
Bob's lawyers and and a whole slew thing
so I say all of that just to say just
just bear with us these things are wrong
we're working on all of them still doing
the show still traveling all that stuff
by the way we're starting to book travel
now my travel gigs now for the fall so
if you want me to come to your college
or your private event or some something
like that you can go to Dave Rubin comm
slash contact there's a forum there and
just submit it I send it over to my
people and if we can work it out I
really I mean the thing that I enjoyed
the most about this past year was
getting out there being on the road and
just meeting so many of you guys and
doing the meet and greets and it's like
it makes it all real it makes it all
real and worthwhile and all that good
stuff so I think that's all I got for
now if you want a classical liberal
shirt there's a link right down below I
think we cleaned up some of the mess I
think we talked about some of the things
this this felt good to me let me have
another sip of water before I leave
there you go I just did an interview
this morning with Robbie suave suave
Robbie suave that's a name Robbie suave
look Robbie suave guys got higher hair
than me that was a little disappointing
but it was a really interesting
interview he's an editor at Reason
magazine and wrote this book which is
coming out in a week or two I've been
reading it's really interesting sort of
gets into all the little the little
micro networks that are just popping up
all over the place from Democratic
socialists and Terps and all right and
just all these little different the
trans feminists and the blah blah blah
and he just sort of talks about all he
actually interviews lots of different
people from all these different groups
and sort of collects all his thoughts
and sort of has a nice sort of
explanation of what's going on on
college campuses particularly at a very
sort of insider level so that's a that's
a good interview that will be up next
week we've got a live stream ladles and
jelly spoons with presidential candidate
Democratic presidential candidate Andrew
yang is this Friday what time is that
gonna be do we know what time can I get
a time can anyone look at me with the
time anyone got a time is there a time I
don't know what time it is I think it's
around noon pacific if i'm not mistaken
around noon pacific 12:30 Pacific Andrew
yang he's agreed to do it live we're
gonna do
I want to talk to him obviously about
universal basic income I want to talk
about identity politics what's going on
with the Democratic Party he strikes me
as a pretty competent really interesting
candidate and we'll have a we'll have a
great conversation maybe maybe mayor
Pete's people watch and go oh you know
that Reuben guy he's for real all right
you know he's not that bad anyway I'm
gonna have a course the same type of
respectful conversation I've had with
anyone else so we're gonna do that on
Friday at 12:30 p.m. Pacific so I hope
you guys will watch that and just
another reminder please click that
subscription thing the subscription
button and make sure the bell says
notifications and all that good stuff
and and you know we crossed a million
thank you guys
we're gonna keep going we're doing our
thing and all right I'm gonna go take
the dog for a walk have a great day
everybody